okay new five-minute game started after
to yahoo this one really bad game before
I'm trying to play you for him and got a
French defense opponent here from Serbia
yeah I've got a um French classical
French Steinitz variation on his plane
should be seven which is a pretty
topical line at the moment um what's
good here not not not sure maybe at one
point I need to take so I do this right
away
and now black should have I mean both
move some look quite okay Bishop c5 195
Queen a five-year also not not out of
the question okay so he he delays the
Sun for a move I don't think I can
really hang on to the porn in a way like
night a four or something looks uh looks
very weird question is where should I
put my bishop now we should be I'd like
to go to d3 but I'm not sure I want to I
always mmm if he takes with a knight now
I always have those okay so he opens up
the position immediately
yeah I don't really want to allow him to
take and giving me a pawn on e5 it would
be wary we can read porn so I take a
take on f6 the question is if he takes
with the bishop now this deform move is
this really am really a threat most
likely it is so what should I play I'm
in this in this Fork so I could move the
night but I don't really have a good
square B 2 also hanging so I could move
the bishop maybe Bishop to f2 was the
sub ma'am I need to get out of the fork
it looks a bit weird um most likely i'm
already am out of established theory how
anything which is known to be great for
white the same looks a like a pretty ok
position for black ok he decided to grab
the end here I don't mind that too much
to be honest because this Bishop f6 was
a super strong piece and I don't I don't
mind the pawns I've got two bishops in
an open position and I have maybe some
attacking possibilities there should be
three ninety-five stuff like this Bishop
g3 also an option and I haven't I didn't
sacrifice anything here for this
position it's not like a bump on down or
something alright so he wants to
release some pressure here hmm and just
hang out maybe a good move I don't want
to play um there should be two Bishop g3
I could I could play yeah okay let's go
here so we exchanged a couple of pieces
here maybe he's got a five now
so the question is what about a move
like rook t1 rugby one threatening then
Bishop c4 stuff like this before i can
take ya know Bishop c4 RM or Bishop
somewhere else is that some other move
or c4 maybe c4 even c4 c4 I can take
okay I need to play quicker here
only four I can capture because of the
pin if you take c4 I can do various
things take on a 7 h-7 twin the Queen
for instance on d4 I have Queenie form
at least Queenie form maybe something
else and I'm threatening to to take on
d5 and putting them in some some ugly
pin not sure what you should should play
here this move okay yeah this some gives
me some opportunities on e5 so Queen III
may be a queen h5 Queen h5m queen at
five and then e 4 I can just retreat
before I can go just Bishop Bishop f1
and now defaults hanging yeah he wants
to amuse this Knight f3 trick but it
looks like his I'm in the pin now on on
this night I simply cannot believe this
for four black can also go Queenie five
yam Queenie five this is just winning
okay I need to have me to be quicker
here maybe maybe King edge one was even
stronger neither three I take we takes
Queen e6 so two bishops in an very open
position and potentially I get the B
pawn Knight f3 I think the only move
that doesn't lose this piece out right
yeah he needs to needs to do this so now
just Queenie form
yeah I hope I don't spoil this time wise
the position looks very promising this
is so maybe into conservative already
still a bit of a tricky nice catching up
a bit on time this is good I'll be seven
is saying maybe he needs to really play
Queen 27 preparing rookie aid also not
really sure that he's got something
better if I can just take b7 the so C
porn should should really decide yeah he
doesn't see it seems like he doesn't
find a move rook f8 I can also go Bishop
t6
Bishop 26 Queen f3 I can exchange Queen
Sofia nuff the two bishops and the
potential see porn huh he doesn't move
for I hope I'm not disconnected or
something no I'm not disconnected and he
doesn't seem to be disconnected maybe
doesn't really find a move I mean black
black seems to be very bad here but I'm
not quite sure why why is not moving no
idea or maybe you got a phone call or
whatever but this looks uh looks very
promising for um for white apt let's
check quickly yeah the comp gives gives
plus free here mm yeah yeah it should be
I mean I'm getting the c-4 ponemos I
think this is the only only move from at
least what I'm seeing here and then I
thought I can I can take here and if he
tries to play this I have 25 this was my
idea at least maybe there's something
better those bishop just also help them
have protect the king this should be it
should be terrible your computer gives
queen exchange and this is over am queen
exchange losses I get a passed pawn here
ANC pawn this should burnham alright so
I'm pretty interesting game not a genie
crash trade I'm pretty interesting game
um I'm not not too sure about this kind
of stuff iam yeah how computer likes why
him and the sea gifts yeah I'm roop do
you only i think i played this pretty
good here pretty well yeah I'd wants to
play Queenie 70 and here i will he we
are here see for blood he wants to play
Queen h5 are of course yeah BM Queen age
5
ani for I can take you for on g6 I can
take g6 so this is even better than c4
it keeps an advantage though see form
here night f5 would have been okay for
black yeah very complicated game yeah
thanks for watching I think it was
pretty pretty interesting okay